all right so there's a new trailer out
there's a trailer for Jurassic world
following Kingdom the Jurassic world
came out it was ultimately a fun monster
movie that lost a lot of the majesty
that made Jurassic Park one of the
Great's of all time but when you accept
that and you fall into Jurassic world
you could have fun with Jurassic world
so what's going into this trailer going
okay not going to be Jurassic Park but
let's see what we got and what we got is
basically an island full of dinosaurs
and the island is yes exploding what do
we call it in a world of sharknado
what's it called now shark Kaena Dino
Kaena sounds like a [ __ ] Mortal
Kombat character it starts out Chris
Pratt and Bryce Dallas Howard they're
small talking good skip pass a small
talk we find out this island is
exploding so it looks like the dilemma
is well there are animals down there
very rare animals extinct animals really
are they subject to the laws the
protection laws do we take them off that
Island cuz they're gonna die if they
stay there then we have Jeff Goldblum is
in this movie I feel like he's gonna be
in this one saying now he's kind of
pumped up at Jeff Goldblum would be in
Jurassic world - Oh crazy but I feel
like it's like at Jeff Golden's in this
one court scene I don't see him going
down there boots on the ground I love
the guy to death but are you really
going to take
pardon my french here a senior citizen
down there to this island that's
exploding to get dinosaurs off of it I
don't see why he would go yes this line
in the trailer where he says dinosaurs
were here before us and if we're not
careful they'll be here after us which
means yes I'm pretty sure he made the
case to just leave the dinosaurs on the
island let them blow up with the island
no possibility of dinosaurs taking out
the human race some of those sapiens win
again now we can kill ourselves on funny
because Bryce Dallas Howard like blues
alive blue being the velociraptor Chris
Pratt trained in the last movie you
almost feel like she's like lassies
alive she's down there we gotta go get
her okay let's go get lassie you can
[ __ ] eat everybody but she saved
everyone's life in the last movie there
you see the islands exploding in the
world work they're ultimately taking
Jurassic Park and they made it a monster
movie in the last movie and now they're
making it a monster slash disaster movie
I guess is what you do I guess you blow
the island up which is the end of this
trailer really does it this is Jurassic
Park 101 at this point Oh Lily Jurassic
Park I'm talking about the first movie
also only Jurassic Park and have danger
dangerous dinosaur coming at you and
then who saves the day boom oh thank God
it's the Tyrannosaurus Rex I've never
felt safer than that Tyrannosaurus Rex
right in front of him Jurassic world he
saved the day
the very first Jurassic Park you saved
the day the lost world that kind of
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] up I guess it was
she they're all females right oh unless
the change of frog DNA thing happened no
I don't know what t-rex is pronoun is
I'm lost
sweat news folks Jurassic world needed
to up it on the dinosaur scale so we got
the indominus rex and now they have to
up that scale so burgers are gonna blow
the place up we have a monster movie
slash disaster movie the majesty of
Jurassic Park is with Jurassic Park this
could be a fun time I hope it's a fun
time well optimism does have its place
and does have its place their optimism
aside is moving my [ __ ] are moving
really exploding Island is so big in
visual scale it's so small and cinematic
vision could be fun after a couple beers
it's not gonna hold my breath for this
one I do want to do a bit of a shout out
and these guys don't know I'm doing this
I'm just doing this because their
channel is genuinely one of my favorite
channels on YouTube right now there's a
channel called my life in gaming and
these guys are dedicated to finding the
optimum way the best way to make your
old-school games look cleaner than
you've probably ever seen them look on
modern TVs if you plugged in your Super
Nintendo to your hi-def television
you're like something looks off it looks
weird and pixelated around the sprite
that's what they're all about they're
all about like here's how you fix that
so you can actually enjoy your game I
love me retro gaming I love what they're
doing it did your Super Nintendo Sega
Genesis are capable of RGB output did
you know that I didn't learned it from
their channel so I'll put a link below
to their channel go check them out if
you love retro gaming trust me you'll be
there with me we gushing about these
guys all right guys so Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom have you seen the trailer
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you